Next, has your ex ever shown up in your dreams uninvited?
(Ross chuckles)
Well, the New York Times reports that experts say
that just because they pop up into your dreams
does not mean that you secretly want them back.
There could be a million reasons for the cameo.
The key is to analyze the dream and in the here and now
from your current emotional state.
They give an example.
One man was thinking of reaching out to an ex spouse,
but then in his dream, she appeared at his house
and then he hid from her in the kitchen.
And when he woke up, he was like,
oh, then I must wanna hide from her in life.
I'm not ready.
I'm not gonna reach out.
Ross, have you had any of your exes come visit your dreams?
You're about to get married.
Yeah, they better not.
They better not show up.
No, no, I don't take a lot...
I don't put a lot of stock in dreams like this,
you know what I mean?
Like the other night I had a dream that I was a camel,
and I could tell you I had a hump and everything.
I could tell you right now with certainty,
I do not want to be a camel, all right?
And so just because you dream of an ex
does not mean you want to be with your ex.
Dreams are like, you know, there's like an encyclopedia,
a Rolodex of things you see in your life,
and dreams are like at rando.
They just pop up.
So chill out.
I've seen a few exes in my nightmares.
Oh, hey.
Yeah, have you ever had a dream of an ex
that made you go, ooh?
I think that's the only place
I'm getting action these days, Ross, is in my dreams.
And every once like every six months
I'll have the hottest dream and I'll be like, oh my God.
Really?
Yes!
Whoa.
And I'm like, oh, I am libidness and alive
Hold on, so what does that word mean?
What was that?
Libidness, like I have a libido.
Like, I'm alive.
I have a pulse.
Libidness.
I just love that in your dreams one of your exes
was all up in your libidness.
(audience applauds)
(Ross laughs)
You know, dreams, they're a safe space
to work of things out as you said.
Oh God, your little mind is fascinating, isn't it?
It's fun to peel you like an onion.
All right, next up.
Here's a question about, oh, anyone here in a group text?
You know what I mean?
Like one of those chats with a bunch of people.
A billion.
Yeah, well, the etiquette is just very blurry.
But this is advice from the column at the Washington Post.
A person wrote in to say that after their husband got COVID,
even though they themselves had tested negative,
they offered to skip
an upcoming outdoor hangout with friends, all right?
And then the friends all agreed that that would be best.
So that person just sat it out.
But their friends, they went on the excursion
and they left them on the group chat.
And then that person felt super left out,
and it hurt them to read all those excited messages
about the event that they were no longer a part of.
So girl, you're on my nerves now.
I just feel like I don't want anyone to feel left out,
but like remove yourself from the text.
Is it that hard, right?
(audience applauds)
I actually asked about that and I was like,
wait can't she just get off the chain?
Yeah, can you mute it or get...
You can remove yourself.
I can't find any circumstance of which
you cannot remove yourself from a text chain.
She said she tried, but couldn't and I...
Raise of hands how many people think
this woman should have, even if she couldn't
get herself off the chain, just stop looking.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Yeah. Uh-huh, I know.
I know.
Do we sound like heartless to her?
'Cause she probably had...
Her feelings were hurt, but your hurt feelings
are becoming my full-time job.
(upbeat bright music)